on va écouter samantha on a affaire un
épisode date de légère accalmie 1 pour
l'instant on a des forces de l'ordre qui
sont à l'écart qui a intenté d'un de
procéder à des interpellations ciblées
pour justement écarter les éléments
radicaux faire en sorte de les
différencier des manifestants des
soignants ça a été compliqué puisque en
face à des forces dehors on a des
centaines d'éléments radicaux des
centaines d'individus cagoulés habillés
de noir des individus et bien qu'ils se
mêlent au reste du cortège donc c'est
très compliqué pour les forces de
l'ordre d'intervenir de maintenir le
calme aujourd'hui alors de ce
rassemblement cette manifestation des
soignants des médecins des infirmiers en
colère qui réclament plus de moyens pour
l'hôpital public ils réclament des
augmentations de salaires 300 euros de
plus par mois pour s'aligner sur la
moyenne européenne ils réclament aussi
des créations de postes l'arrêt des
fermetures d'établissements de service
denis il faut savoir qu'au cours des six
dernières années 17500 l'iran disparu
dans les hôpitaux publics donc voilà ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que beaucoup
de matériel urbain a été dégradé des
poubelles ont été incendiées on a des
pompiers qui sont aussi mobilisé
beaucoup de street mais dick qui
interviennent cet après midi pour venir
en aide aux blessés on est blessé et qui
se comptent par dizaines
ici sur cette place des invalides on a
des manifestants les journalistes
également qu'ils ont été blessés dont
l'un des nôtres à chaussures rt france
donc voilà les gaz lacrymogènes
répondre systématiquement aux jets de
projectiles on a des manifestants
derrière qui scandent assez
régulièrement à des slogans hostiles aux
forces de l'ordre mais également aux
gouvernements des slogans qui ont visé
et christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur mais également emmanuel
macron le président de la république qui
on réclame la démission
voilà une manifestation qui avait bien
commencé dans la bonne humeur au départ
du ministère de l'intérieur ministère de
la santé pardon et qui sait a dégradé
qui a dégénéré ici sur cette place des
invalides une situation encore très
critique ici il est 17h et la plume et
il ya toujours autant de monde en sueur
sur cette place des invalides on va
rejoindre deux infirmiers de l'hôpital
de dreux qui ont fait le déplacement
aujourd'hui pour faire entendre leur
colère ils estiment avoir été abandonné
par par le gouvernement alexandre vous
êtes infirmier vous pourquoi
déjà vous êtes ici aujourd'hui ici tout
d'abord pour faire entendre notre cause
pour pouvoir faire comprendre entre
guillemets aux dirigeants qu on l a déjà
pour soigner les gens
ok on reçoit un salaire pour ça on est
pas assez d'effectifs depuis des années
des années les budgets sont serrés les
budgets sont bloqués les gens sont
malheureusement nous parfois mal soignée
avec toute la bonne volonté qu'on puisse
puis si m on est là aujourd'hui pour
essayer de faire entendre notre voix
ouais vous pensez que ça fait des années
et des années que les derniers les les
gouvernements successifs les précédents
gouvernements ont taillé dans les
effectifs ont diminué les budget vous
pensez que cette crise est liée aux
copies de 19 elle a révélé les failles
du système de santé français tout à fait
elle a réveillé alors révélé non
seulement les failles mais la capacité
des dirigeants à on va dire à répondre à
une demande ponctuelle voilà des mises
des milieux d'hôpitaux on s'organise
ouais malgré des milliards dépensés
qu'est ce que vous réclamez vous êtes
infirmier ça se passe comment au
quotidien votre votre profession au
quotidien comment ça se passe on reçoit
des personnes dont là on la choisit
aussi
certes c'est dur on est là pour ça le
point central nous dans notre boulot
c'est le patient convient qui est
accueilli à l'hôpital et qu'on soigne du
mieux qu'on peut vous inspire et bien la
suite de cette manifestation aujourd'hui
complètement dégénéré sur cette pièce
des envies d'ailleurs n'a pas pu finir
notre parcours on a été en a été
encerclé ici des familles ont été ont
été gazés aussi
est-ce que ce qu'on veut pas nous mettre
des bâtons dans les roues est ce qu'on
veut c'est ce qu'on veut pas on va dire
à étouffer un petit peu là
un autre était personne violente pour
décrire attendait alexis on va rejoindre
alexis vous vous me dites alexis alexis
oui je disais que ya un peu de gilet
jaune isation en fait on va faire penser
que la manifestation est violente pour
nous décrédibiliser le discours du
discours il est réel on a besoin de
moyens on a besoin de collègues en plus
on a besoin d'un peu plus aussi pour
vivre parce que parce qu'un infirmier
s'est scellée c'est noël c'est laid
c'est l'anniversaire de son fils c'est
l'essai s'est laissé une partie de sa
vie ou au service des autres et derrière
et derrière voilà on ne manque pas grand
chose
on demande pas grand chose un peu de
reconnaissance un petit peu plus de
d'argent par rapport à notre spécificité
on a travaillé très très technique moi
je suis infirmier en psychiatrie
j'ai été mobilisé pour le govic j'ai dû
revoir mes compétences les remettre en
les remettre en action donc on on nous
demande une gamme de savoir et on ne
paye pas en conséquence on ne paye pas
en conséquence de ce qu'on nous prend
cette prime kovy delà de 1000 1500 euros
elle suffit pas assez bien mais c'est
pas assez
franchement ça va être ça va être dur ce
que je vais dire mais j'ai l'impression
d'avoir été pris de court une escorte
quoi on s'est servi de moi on me jette
maintenant allez prends tes 1500 et
vatan la couleur de l'eau de l'hôpital
elle est bien plus profonde que ça comme
vous en parliez tout à l'heure ça fait
dix ans qu'il ya des coupes budgétaires
ça fait dix ans qu'on nous met des
administratifs en plus et pour obtenir
le moindre médicament ou le moindre
matériel de soin c'est compliqué ça
passe par des bons ça passe par des
systèmes informatiques qui font des
cotations
on nous informe tout le temps de ce
qu'on dépense comme si nous nous le seul
intérêt qu'on a dans là dedans c'est la
vie humaine intérêts financiers on peut
pas travailler avec ces ségur de la
santé alors vous
y croyez pas on a invité les infirmiers
participer ce sera ma réponse on n'y est
pas pourquoi est-ce que vous avez tenu à
venir aujourd'hui emmanuel macron lors
de son allocution dimanche il a dit aux
français de limiter justement d'éviter
les rassemblements
vous avez pas forcément écouté les
consignes du président de la république
pourquoi parce que la colère elle est
trop fort c'est que danger j'ai été mis
trois mois en danger dans un service
qu'ovide par manque de matériel d'accord
ça a été cautionnée par l'état tout le
monde pouvait commander des masques
qu'ils ont juste interdit de le faire je
prend pas plus de risques d'être
infectés autres autour de 30 patients
qu'aux vide à l'heure actuelle ce sera
ma réponse je suis pas plus dangereux
j'avais de l'espoir quand même que ça
s'améliore parce qu'on dit on demande
beaucoup d'argent à l'hôpital public est
ce que est ce qu'on en a suffisamment
dans les caisses de l'état de l'argent
je pense que pour certains intérêts
ouais il ya de l'argent et puis pas pour
d'autres il y en a pas pour la santé
pour le social il ya ça fait longtemps
qu'ils a plus beaucoup dans les caisses
quoi après voilà faut peut-être répartir
les caisses quoi vous faut réfléchir
autrement mais de toute façon cette
crise elle a montré que sont l'hôpital
ne serait pas grand chose quoi merci
beaucoup à alexis merci à vous également
alexandre infirmiers je le disais à
l'hôpital de dreux donc on voit là une
manifestation qui se poursuit ici à
place des invalides avec de nombreux à
épisodes de tensions entre les forces de
l'ordre d'un côté et plusieurs éléments
radicaux de l'autre qui est bien veulent
en découdre en découdre avec les forces
de l'ordre d'une manifestation qui se
poursuit
difficilement je vous propose d'écouter
certains manifestants justement
aujourd'hui qui ont tenu à participer
aujourd'hui à cette manifestation trouve
inadmissible le fait qu'on vienne pour
voilà en fait un clamait nos droits et
nos du compte on retrouve en fait
encercler comme deux voleurs assure gaz
et avoir les yeux qui pleurent de nez
qui pique avec des bombes lacrymogènes
concil tout à fait et en soignant que
c'est très dangereux moi je trouve ça
inadmissible et le fait que voilà nous
remet quand même bonne santé en jeu pour
venir en aide à la population et
construit comment fait on cercle et
comme des voleurs trouve ça inadmissible
faudrait peut-être que le gouvernement
se réveille parce que c'est bien beau de
derrière un bureau est de donner des
conseils mais quand on est sur le
terrain même ce n'est pas la même fin
actuellement les hôpitaux son manque de
matériel en manque d'effectif
ça je le dis haut et fort on se retrouve
maintenant dans des services avec votre
passion pour un an ferme et une
étonnante
c'est inadmissible cocoon et puis si on
n'est pas écoutés on se sent délaissé il
faudrait que l'étape fait quelque chose
ou sinon de mal finir parce que vu qu on
nous prend comme des délinquants bas
s'ils continuent comme ça les gens vont
se rendre compte aider la con on est
systématiquement contre la violence mais
le pouvoir a décidé qu'il jouerait sur
la violence sur la violence sur la
violence pour dire regardez c'est infect
gens ces soignants à qui on disait bravo
bravo et bien aujourd'hui on va les
craintes et bientôt comme dédé dangereux
personnage et les voilà ce fameux peuple
turovsky avec de l'ardeur il ne fait
pourquoi mais il le fait parce qu'il ne
peut plus les submerger bon l'autre lui
donne une dette auquel s'ajoutait de 40%
ben on a fermé plus de 2300 sociétés
nationales ont 20 ans qu'à augmenter en
fait le chômage de plus de 10 e de 2009
6,2 de personne ne va y avoir une vague
au coeur de millions de personnes qui
vont arriver
on va arriver où là on va aller jusqu'au
bout ça m'attriste profondément
parce que depuis le début tout se passer
correctement c'était une manifestation
bon enfant on sait se faire entendre et
en arriver à attaquer les forces de
l'ordre je suis pas sûr que nous ça nous
serve à quelque chose
le les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté alors on les salue
on a du respect pour
voilà est allé leur foncer dedans ou
leur balancer des trucs directement
c'est inacceptable ça fait quand même
assez mal après ce qui s'est passé en
france avec l'épidémie comme président
de voir que des le premier rassemblement
bon ben voilà c'est le même traitement
qui est donnée donc un jour on cogne sur
les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est des
soignants c'est du grand n'importe quoi
l'espoir c'est que les gens se rendent
compte petit à petit de la façon dont
est gouvernée
voilà je pense que ça devient criant bon
après on peut toujours garder les yeux
fermés
mais à partir mans les ouvre ça devient
assez évident quand même ne sommes pas
écoutés
nos revendications ne sont pas prises en
compte
[Musique]
oui donc voilà une manifestation qui se
poursuit avec un face à face
actuellement 3 les forces de l'ordre qui
est en recul
un petit peu et quelques manifestants
qui font face aux forces de l'ordre on a
beaucoup de matériel urbain abîmé des
poubelles incendiées regardé un seul
incendie on a de nombreuses routes et
qui ont été à d'ehpad et donc on va à
une situation est très tendue
je vous parlais tout à l'heure
d'éléments radicaux et bien cette place
des invalides
elle serait suivie d'un au fur et à
mesure on sent que voilà on se dirige
vers une fin de manifestation
voilà en tout cas on peut peut-être
commencer à parler de retour au au calme
même si la tension est toujours palpable
elle s'est vidée à cette place des
invalides on a beaucoup moins d'éléments
radicaux que tout à l'heure il reste
uniquement quelques quelques
manifestants quelques membres du
personnel soignant actuellement et
quelques gilet jaune aussi qui sont
présents aujourd'hui neige pour toutes
ces informations
[Musique]